車が家です。これが新時代のルームツアです。
そうなんです。
どうにか1
人暮らしできないかって考えた時に物減らせばいいんじゃないか。
うん。
物減らして最初がもう1万9000
円のもう6畳1Kのもう蓄年数30
年のマンションとかそうすると物のが少ないから
畳でも全然広く生活できるし引っ越し費用も
7万円くらい済んだんすよ。
でかつ家賃も安いから月
6枚で生活してて
お仕事で何があります?
オンラインお片付きの指導があります。
あ、オンラインで
もう1時間みんな60
分画面繋ぎながらもう片付け集中しようていう大体
名とかバレルの打ち合わせとかもありますね。僕のこと知らない人でも買えるような
うん。
機能シンプルなデザインのものしてるから元々収集壁みたいもそんなない感じなんですかね?
ありましたよ。
めっちゃ昔は元々物多い状態からミニマリストなってるっていう
きっかちあったんですかなんか。
ああ、でもやっぱ元々僕
二郎大学行ってないんだよ。クズだった自分を変えるためにミニマリストになったっていうのが最初の始まりですね。
すいません。鈴木と申します。本日よろしくお願いいたします。
はい、よろしくお願いします。ミニマリストしです。
今日なんかご自宅に伺うみたいなお話をお聞きしてたんですが
はい。
これから向かう形ですかね?
あ、ここです。もうついてます。
え、あ、これ
はい。
あ、え、車じゃないですか?
はい。車が家です。
あ、そうなんですか。
はい。毎日車中泊ミニマリストだから持ち物少ないし、
車の中に全部入るなっていうので、
あ、はい。
ま、これだったら移動する家になるなと思って。
あ、なるほどです。ました。
こういう形のルームツアーはやったことはないんですけど。
はい。で、これが新時代のルームツアです。
そうなんですね。ここがまあ玄関になります。
[笑い]
家の鍵が実はなくて、
ま、このアプリに全部収まってるんですけど、今からありちゃいます。はい。おお。
あ、本当に。
はい。
寝室が、あ、でも広いですね。
そうなんですよ。あの、ま、僕が乗ってる車がテスラのモデル
Y
っていう車で、ま、結構広いです。ベッドと
はい。
冷蔵庫。
あ、
と、
あ、冷蔵庫なんですね、これ。
はい。
あとここが収納で、ま、あのテーブルとか
ああ、こういう形で置いてあげるとここでご飯食べたりなんかも置いて
ていうようなここで基本はずっとあ、
冷蔵庫って見てもいいですか?
はい、冷蔵庫はい。中身
はい。
こういう形でこのテスラの
この収納にスポット
シンデレラフィットで入る。
あ、
冷蔵庫でこんな形で、
え、
ここに入って下の方まで入るっていうな、
あ、すごい。
アイスクリームとかも冷やせますよ。ここで温度調整がこうやってピってマイナ
6°まで
すごい
できるんで、
もうアイス食べたかったら行けます。あ、お水どうぞ。
あ、ありがとうござ[笑い]
プラスで、えっと、前にも空間がて
はい。
で、ここがま、仕事部屋なんですけど。
はい。あ、でもなんかこっちも広いですね。確か。
そうです。
ミニマリストなんで上いらないなと思ってここ切りました。打ち抜きました。丸じゃなくていいなと思って。
[笑い]
丸くなくて困らないですか?運転とかは。
これなんでハンドルって丸くある必要あるんですか?ここで成り立つじゃないですか。ここの差し式でこうやって。
[笑い]
確かはい。ああ。
はい。
一応僕はこのテスラって車選んだ理由が車界のミニマリストって言われててラ自体がそのもうミニマリストデザインってすごい海外とかでも
うん。なんかすっきりしてますよね。すごい。
あ、そうなんです。もうあの操作系の物理ボタンが一切なくて
ここの操作で完結するんですよ。エアコンって一般的にここにレバーがあったりするじゃないですか。
はい。
それがなくて全部ここのもうタッチパネルでやっちゃうっていうの。
へえ。
このシンプルな空間だから仕事はどるんすよ。
あ、いので、これが折りたのチェスラ専用ディスクで、
お、
開くとこの幅にぴったしはまるんですよ。パソコンを。
開いたらもう本当に仕事環境になるっていうな。本当にこの椅子がめっちゃいいからずっとここで仕事もできるし、音声入力であの会話したりするので喋りながら仕事したい時とかはここに喋りかけながら音声入力で仕事したりとか。
[音楽]
うん。へえ。
こですね。
ええ。
あの、ここにオールシーズン全の服が入ってます。
おお、すごい。
まだ余ってますけどね。もう少し入るぐらい。
まだ余ってます。
こう、あの、エンジンがないんですよ。
すごいですね。
はい。モーターで走るんで、バッテリーとモーターが車の底に詰まれてるからうん。
ま、ここがスペースがあくっていうスピードとかも全然ガソリン車より早かったりするし、ミニマリストに電気
自動車おすすめで、あの、部品点数が少ないからオイル交換とかメンテナンスの手も少ない。
ああ、はい、はい。
管理もしやすいし、
先日電気台が
万円だったんですけど、多分これガソリン車だったら
56万ぐらいかかってるってような。
確かに
先月4000kmとか走ってますよね。
あ、すごい。
の時にやりたいことリストみたいな書いて、そん中の
1つにありました。車で暮らすみたいな。
[笑い]
あ、そうなんですか。
ありました。YouTube
の企画でなんか視聴者さんのお家に行って、ま、訪問をお片つきみたいな
ことをやってるんですけど、そうい時やっぱ車がないと結構撮影に行けないような場所から応募があったりとか、あと片付けをする時にやっぱりあの素大ゴミとかが出てくるのでパリ面の段階で注文しました。これ
うん。ええ、
もうやるって決めたらすぐやりますね。迷ってる時間がもったいないから。
ああ、すごい。
むしろ捨てることを何回も繰り返して、ま、その視選択の訓練できてるから捨てるのも買うのも早くな。
うん。本日は予定としてはどんな形になるんですか?今日は
ちょうどこの後ですね、
えっと朝の9
時からえっとオンラインお片付きの指導があります。
あ、オンラインで
はい。僕YouTube
の企画として視聴者さんの家に片付けるっていう企画と並行して有料でオンラインの片付け教えててでそれがもうリアルタイムで
Zoom
をつなぎながらその生徒さんと一緒に片付けるっていうもう
1時間みんな60
分画面繋ぎながらもう片付け集中しようっていう。
あ、それ何名ぐらい繋ぐんですか?
大体50名とかそうですね。
ま、基本はこういう形だからもうそうですね、スマホのインターネット共有であ、
はい。
繋いで
今こういう形であの今事前に人が入ってきてます。こうやってバわバわばわ。
なるほど。
はい、皆さんおはようございます。ということで本日
3月7日土曜日のZoom
作業会始めていきます。よろしくお願いします。本日も作業会頑張りましょう。よろしくお願いします。香おりさんおはようございます。
今日は火事を片付けて書類の見直しですってことで、お、いいですね。ま、結構あのこのズー作業界書類の見直しされてる方も多いですね。
こ日常的に目に入らないからなんかそういう理由あってちょっと仕事のモチベーションが上がらないのかなと思って
うん。うん。
そしたらものすごく墓ったんですよね、仕事が。
うん。うん。うん。
なので、あの、台は一旦なくして、
ちょうどプログラムもあと残り1ヶ月、2
ヶ月経過して結構変化が出てきてたりとか、少なく探し物が減ったとか、さっき言ったメニマムライフストが通安くなったとか、色々皆さんも変化感じてきてると思いますし、やればやるほどどんどん変化出てくるので、あの、ラスト
回ですね、ま、後悔ないように皆さん頑張りましょう。お疲れ様でした。良い週末を。はい、ということで終わりました。
いやあ、本当にお疲れ様でした。
そうですよね。1
時間ぶっ通して喋ってるから意外と集中力使うんすよ、これ。結構しかも質問がアドリブでくるから僕もすごいこれ勉強になるんですよ。
聞きながらAI
叩いて調べたり部やっぱり僕がパッと答えれないこととかも調べながら答えたりするから結構アドリブ能力も磨かれし
片付けだけじゃなくてさっきの保険のこととか
デジタル周りのこととかインテリアのこととかも生活のこと全部教えてるんで教える幅が広いがうに僕もたくさん学ばないといけなくて
単純に物減らして片付けるだけじゃなくて物お金デジタルっていうこと
つの側面で教えてるから受行する人は本当にもうなんかありがたいこと
にもう渋ぶさんのプログラム受けてすごい人生行きやすくなりましたとか、ま、無駄な出費減ってとかプログラムの料金もなんかもう余裕で回収できましたとか皆さんもやっぱ
ヶ月間っていう期間が決まってるから残り
ヶ月だから公開ないようにちょっと後半追い上げましょうみたいな片付けできない人って根本片付の優先順位が低いんすよ。かかる時間を甘く見積もりすぎ。
YouTubeの片付企画も1
歩の動画がなんか2時間とか長いやつ5
時間あるんですよ。その裏には実はもう
30時間とか20時間とか
片付けてだから30
時間の動画素材を片付けの時間を
時間に圧縮してみたいな。で、ましてはそこにお金とかデジタルも整理もしてくんで、
だから受生の人には必ずこのプログラムに対して最低
時間は時間取ってくださいっていうんですよ。
1回
もうここ来ちゃえば
もうどんどん手が進んでで多分この
時間が終わった後も今も多分皆さん形頑張ってんですよ。この
なるほどなるほど。1番どい01
のところをサポートしてるっていう
はい。終わってですけど、これからは何を?
最近ちょっと行ってみたいカフェがあるからそこを入って個別の対応をしていくっていう。
これシフトレバーないんですよ、この車は。
あ、そうでしたね。[笑い]
あのカフェでは何の作業?
さっきのあの片付けへのプログラム
を申し込んでくれてる人に対してえっと
1対1のあのLINEを開します。
さっきのグループズomって形だったので
1対1
で質問が来てたりするので、ま、それに返していくっていうような
ことを大体午前中とか昼までにそれをまとめてやっちゃいますね。
あとはお仕事で言うと他には何があります?
ま、それ以外だと大体YouTube
撮ってることが多かったり、オフ会っていう形で、ま、ちょっと勉強会みたいなのをやるので、なんかそれの資料を作ったりとか。うん。
そ、基本片付け回りというか、
バレルの打ち合わせとかもありますね。
物づりやってる会社さんと一緒にやっていて、僕は、えっと、商品の企画デザインと、ま、集客宣伝っていうところをやってて、うちの商品でなんか
[音楽]1
番人気なのが手ブライコバッグっていう真角に畳める製法系のカがあって、
ちょうどデジ袋有料化のタイミングとかですごいおかげ様で売れて、王様のブランチとかそういう全国のテレビでなんか僕は出ないんだけど、エコバックだけがもう人気ですごい紹介されて売
入れてくみたいなインフルエンサーブランドってなんかファングッズみたいな多かった。
そのイメージが私あります。
そう。なんか例、ま、分かりやすいとこでその人のなんか
ロゴが載ってるとかうちのブランドはそういうの一切なんかファング的なものではなくて僕のこと知らない人でも買えるような
うん。
機能シンプルなデザインのものにしてるから、ま、僕自身もミニマリストっていう目線で作ってるから、ま、売る以上は不要なもの売りたくないというか、ま、ちゃんと長く使ってもらえてかつ持つことで逆に身軽になれる。
みたいな。
元々収集壁みたいもそんなない感じなんですかね。
ありましたよ。めっちゃ昔は元々物の多い状態からミニマリストなってるっていう。
きっかけちあったんですか?なんか
ああ、でもやっぱ元々僕フリーターって話したと思うんですけど。
はい。
二ロし大陸大学行ってないんだ僕。
二して大学行かなかったっていう。
そうです。
現役の時になんか地元の国率の大学行くつもりで、ま、家からも近いし、ま、そもそもあの実家が自己、自己破散してるので。
あ、そうなんですか。
そうです。
チり追加せるお金ないよっていうので、その
A
判定で余裕でしょうと思ってた大学すら受からずセンター試験で思いっきり滑ったんで
あ書いて滑り止めもきず新学校に通ってたから、ま、トップの人は東大行ってるとか早稲田早期行ってる子もいたので医学部とか浪人するからにはもっといいとこ受からなきゃみたいななんかプライドで浪人するからデブレとこ行けるでしょみたいな
年勉強するなしみたいなっていうところからどんどんまともに勉
せずバイト形
稼いだお金はアニメのね関連のグッズ買う
とかそういう趣味のことにどんどんお金
使っちゃって老人のかぶったフリーター
みたいなもう周りはさっきた東大早医学部
とか言っててもうみんな就職の話とかし
てるんですよね。
で、その一方で俺大学も行けないし、フリーターで当てもないしみたいなところでせめてでも実家を抜けて自立して
人暮らしすれば、ま、まだ世間定保てるなみたいなところからじゃあどうしよう。どうやったら
人暮らしできるか。で、もうフルタイムでバイトしたくないしなみたいな。
うん。
どうにか1
人暮らしできないかって考えた時に物減らせばいいんじゃないか。うん。
物減らして最初がもう1万9000
円のもう6畳のもう年数
30[音楽]
年のマンションとかそうするとものが少ないから
畳でも全然あの広く生活できるし引っ越し費用も初期費用家具家電も買った上で
7万円くらい済んだんすよ。でかつ家賃も
安いからもう保険の費用とかサブスク
スマホ台ジムジム費用とか全部入れて月
6万生活しててクズだった自分を変える
ためにミニマリストになったっていうのが
最初の始まりですね。
財布でもいいと思うので是非。そうですね。一旦あのお子さんからもらった
なんかしさん今日朝から密着してて
はい。
まだご飯食べてない。
はい。あ、そうです。僕食べないです。昼ランチはえっと
朝も
朝も食べないです。朝ももう水飲んだだけ。
この後夕方にあのヤギ君ご飯食べるからもうそん時までは食べないですね。
やさんっていうのはどうなった?
はい。
やり君はなんか、ま、僕のブロガー時代の友達
年ぐらいの仲間になるのかな。それこそなんかあのブログをやってたんですけど、最初っからミニマリストブログをやってたわけではなく、それこそアニメとか漫画の感想とかなんか色々書いたんですよ。
はい。
それを見たや君が、ま、渋はやっぱりミニマリストぶりが尖ってるからミニマリストに絞ったらみたいなアドバイスを受けてミニマリストのことで書くようになってすごい読まれるようになったっていう。
そう意味はすごい気づきあの与えてくれた友達です。
今からやギ君とご飯なので
はい。
それまでさっきそうですね、カフェで仕事してこっち来たっていう。
結構は取りました。
そうですね。もうはって今日のノ間は達成したんで
あとはもうゆっくりご飯できます。
さすがにお腹減ってんじゃないですか。
もう腹ペコなんで。
そうです。
ういす。お疲れ様です。
ヶ月から半年ぐらいですね。ちょこちょこの東京であったね。
いただきます。[音楽]
いただきます。
すげえ贅沢な。
当時支部全然金なかったもんな。
そう。貧コンフリーターだっ。
[笑い]
しは元々ね、ブロガーのオンラインサロンに入ってくれたんだよね。
そう。ブログの書き方教えるみたいね。
ま、その時は渋はファッションのブログ書いたり、ザッキブログ書いたりしてて。
そう。もう色々本の条約とかグルメとかガジェットとかも何でも書いてうん。うん。
[鼻息]
コミュニティサロンに入してもらって
そのオフ会みたいなのが行ってて福岡に住んでたからそこで仲良くなった。キャンピングカー生活やめた後に福岡に引っ越したんすよね。
ああ。
あ、奥もかなり空っぽいので福岡も結局
[笑い]
年もすんじゃない気がするけど。うんうん。そうね。
1年いないぐらい。
うん。自分のやりたいこととニーズがマッチしてるとね。ま、続けられるよね。
うん。
僕が結構得意なのがその人の
やりたいことと
その市場の流れというか世間のニーズみたいな
をバチッとはめるのがめっちゃ得意でに今それをやってるんで自己理解でやりたいことわかんない人多いなっていうのを僕が超興味あるしみんなも今知りたいよねみたいなタイミングでバーンって当てるから本が爆売れしたりとか
[鼻息]
[音楽]
するんすよね。関わってくれた人のやばい
ところを社会に受け入れさせるというか、
やってれて楽しいしで続けられるから当然
成果も出るしずっとやってるから自分の
本質をただ表現表現してうまくいっ
るってだけなんですよね。シも全く同会う
までうまくいってなかったけど自分の
めっちゃやりたいところ社会バチはったら
もう楽しくて仕方なくなるから[笑い]
なんかさああに社会に居場所があった
みたいになるじゃん。
その時に初めて人の天才性って解放されてあ
うん。能力が使えるんですよね。
うん。
でもみんながやってるのって逆でもっと成長しなきゃとか自分を変えなきゃ新しいものを身につけなきゃっていうスタンスで生きるじゃないですか。それが逆にうまくいかない原因になってて、もう持ってるんすよね。うん。
うん。それをただ出す、出せる場所に適合するだけっていう。確かに
[音楽]
うん。しもね、もう会社人とかやってたら超社会不適合者でしょ。
うん。[笑い]
会社員絶対やったら終わってた。
片付けのオンラインサービス作ろうぜって
言ったのも去年とかだよね。
そう。本当1
年半前とか顔出しするとか部屋公開するってすごいリスクもあるしもう多いもの
[音楽]
万再生とかされてるから出る出然のハードルが上がっちゃって
お金払うからもうそのプライベートで受けたいみたいな声が来るようになってそっからサービスになったっていうその時にも相談してましたね。
[音楽]
なんかね。
うん。
本出す前もそうなした。先に本出してたからブラできる出版してて渋谷であったかな。渋谷で飯食ってる時にどうやったら売れんのみたいな聞いて僕は今
[音楽]
60万も売れてますけど。
え、僕は10万なんで、[笑い]
あの、抜かれました。抜かれまし余裕ですごいこっちの方が
今後の目標というか何をするみたいになったして
うん。
僕自身の生活を面白くしていかないとコンテンツにも反映されないなと思ってるので、そういう意味で車生活を始めたのはそれ
[音楽]
1つチャレンジですね。
めっちゃこっからも行きそうだよね。
うん。まだまだ女装中です[音楽]
ね。
もっとすぎ。
ああ。いや、
ただまだまだこれからって感じなんです。
これからすよ。
もう
うん。
お疲れ様でした。もう夜真っ暗になりましたね。
この後名古屋に移動するんで僕の一緒にお片せて行った人のインタビューみたいなその後は福島行ってみたいな行きつく間もないですね。
[笑い]
ね、もう本当毎日どっかチェで移動してます。
今日動画見て興味持ってくださった方は、あの、僕のあの公式
[音楽]
LINE
があって、ま、そこで物が捨てられない人向けの
の質問リストとかスマホのホーム画面をミニマルにデザインカスタマイズできるアプリアイコン画像とか色々得典
13個くらいAIの支に相談できるAI
シとか作ってるです。今っぽいでしょ?
今っぽい。
全部無料なんで。では、ではありがとうございました。でした。
[音楽]